auf und davon mit immobilien
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
böse überraschung kurz vor dem
notartermin in der toskana
[Musik]
aufgreifen und beschrieben wie
sie
das landstück sich
leben in der toskana für ein eigenes
agriturismo lösen eva dunkle und philips
weiter matti ihren haushalt auf
beim rundgang mit der maklerin entdeckt
philipp eva will den ofen ebenerdig
einbauen lassen
[Musik]
also definitiv zeit da nicht etwas was
ich jetzt nicht schrecken verloren haben
sicher nicht ganz dass aus mir gemacht
hat für
micro stettler wird ein traum wahr
[Musik]
zusammen mit seiner frau marina mara und
hündin gina ziehen sie an die usa in
florida wollen sie ein waffel restaurant
eröffnen
sie sind franchise nehmer einer gastro
kette das training im waffelbacken haben
sie erfolgreich absolviert
nachdem
familie wieser kehrt der schweiz den
rücken zu und wandert mit ihrer kleinen
herde nach frankreich aus bauer sandro
glaubt trotz erfolgreicher wirtschaften
zu können sich durch andere perspektive
haben andere cashflow marge noch nichts
sagen aber der bläser zahltag mich
natürlich ganz klar dass man
was man hat nimmer ist gestand die
heimliche an der atlantikküste erwartet
die visa ein riesiger hof mit 400 tieren
[Musik]
noch bleibt alexandra in oberhof sandro
fährt schon voraus der tiertransporter
mit visa jährige ist seit vier stunden
unterwegs das ziel
[Musik]
zwölf stunden
länge können sollten noch einmal
sächlichen überholen
und
das gleichzeitige
jeder 40 transport des schimmels
gewisses restrisiko und
warum ruft sich nimmt er respektiere die
eu verlassen
und hoffe natürlich dass es das glück
gehabt
und schon die erste große reise oder
tiere
[Musik]
der bauer möchte fuhr seinen tieren auf
dem hof in frankreich ankommen
so sehr auf halber wegstrecke kann er
sie einholen
der sender zufrieden
sie sind dennoch
new york
ich hoffe dass meine saison statt platz
[Musik]
tampa in florida
im norden der stadt in einer ruhigen
wohngegend haben schweizer die berner
flagge gehisst seit drei monaten ist der
karten take place das neue daheim von
marina und meint da ich freue mich sehr
auf akw und friesen fragen dass sie
sprüche und jeder hätte die partie hatte
ich sehr viel und westbahn
afghanistan
in den usa zu leben davon träumte mike
seit über 20 jahren und
der marina schon seit kindertagen das
fernweh plagt war sie sofort dabei
[Musik]
einzige bedingungen yu na die hündin sie
musste mit du
ein eigenes business ein waffel shop in
tampa für ein leben in den usa haben sie
ihre familien und freunde rund 8000
kilometer hinter sich gelassen
werden und es ist
doch ihr traum kam ins trudeln kam in
den usa angekommen brach gronaus und
mike hat plötzlich viel zeit was einem
schlag ein buch
wie st
und ich bin also noch erhält quasi
etwas nicht haben strack und möbel und
zieht rennen hat er da eigentlich im
minimum mit dem netz längst alles sah
danach aus
caritas stellt fürs lackieren
halt was sie richtig
wegen der pandemie kommt der umbau ihres
waffe restaurants kaum vom fleck doch
die kosten laufen weiter anschaffungen
versicherungen paus und lokal miete
müssen trotzdem bezahlt werden
weiteres problem die
einwanderungsbehörde arbeitet nur
reduziert visums verlängerungen werden
zur zitterpartie
erst nach etlichen mails und anrufen
bekam marina ihre verlängerung zum
gesichert noch fehlt die schriftliche
bestätigung
dass ich natürlich schon tag war
zwar nicht der hänger gesteckt dazu
heißt plan b
das quad auf eis gelegt nachdem corona
gut ich mache
mir gar nichts
wir aber nichts im umbau sie also sehr
viel geld investiert mehr in asien
stand zum schluss einfach daran dass sie
partout sieht allgemeine
ja das ist nur eines ist es ist kalt und
diese existenz verlieren ist neues leben
aufbauen und ist schon bewusst sind dass
ein stopp stehend aber die letzte woche
mit dem krones hat einfach mix aus musik
zu verstehen
ist machtlos aber grundsätzlich vitro es
kaum möglich sie das cologne als
verhindert dass mit diesem schluss
kommen dass haben möglich sei
große momente
sicher auch was denn sie bestätigt haben
und siehe da ist halt verlängern sie hat
in texas und gut microscan tut mir
willst du nicht wenn und aber das kommt
gut an
sagt du hast
mit passion
marina hat das talent immer wieder das
beste aus seiner situation zu machen und
das scheint anzustecken
[Musik]
noch in der schweiz im tösstal ist eva
dude obwohl schon drei jahre in rente
arbeitet sie noch immer
[Musik]
partner philipp ist frisch pensioniert
rentenalter hin oder her die beiden sind
mit hohem tempo unterwegs
besser
[Musik]
vielleicht ist es das alter entschlüsse
sind schnell gefasst kleine differenzen
bald vergessen jetzt wisst wegen des
ofens darüber kann philipp heute nur
noch lachen
also der cup auch hoffe ich
ja ja ja
ja
du dann nämlich durchaus zu suchen damit
man irgendwann zurück und einigermaßen
von der bohrstelle
als jacob
philip freist voraus noch wenige tage
und der ehemalige sicherheitsbeauftragte
der flughafenpolizei wird seine neue
aufgabe als gutsverwalter ihres
agriturismo antreten
[Musik]
die fahrt durch frankreich verlief
optimal
in sacrow auf der linke seite rechts
abbiegen
so
setzen wir auf die straße
[Gelächter]
schaut sie
ja
im stall erwartet in patrice hondo
hondo ist einer der vorbesitzer des hofs
lisicki er wird sandro auch nach dem
verkauf unterstützen
gegen 10 uhr in der nacht dann kommt
auch sandvoss kleine her der aus dem
aargau an
[Applaus]
jetzt widerrufen
inzwischen ist der aufstieg
[Applaus]
die hand
gehabt
[Musik]
die klassen sind
endlich wieder rumspringen zum ersten
mal in französischen strom
[Musik]
schafft schafft wissenschaft
wissenschaftslandschaft
ich bin froh
dass das nicht funktioniert sie nicht
passt was
[Musik]
die südliche toskana di maria das ist
die neue heimat von eva und philipp
[Musik]
als gutsverwalter trifft philip mit
gärtner massimo masai die ersten
vorkehrungen
damit sie als agriturismo gelten müssen
die zürcher vorlagen erfüllen eine davon
landwirtschaft betreiben philipp lässt
800 olivenbäume anpflanzen
[Musik]
die probleme so lala simulator semester
polizei und die politik und kapital
ein kleines stück jede seines oliven
heims ist anders beschaffen als der rest
die quali gerne vater prima
wenn zug ist ja
die reihe und moltke prominente und
marika die und die una vita
kommentieren
[Musik]
ein stück land auf dem nichts wächst
noch nimmt das philipp gelassen
[Musik]
tampa in florida fünf autominuten von zu
hause entfernt haben mike und marina das
geschäftslokal für ihren waffel shop
gemietet dieses befindet sich so richtig
amerikanisch in einer mall dem brand
plaza shoppingcenter typisch auch hier
gibt es viele parkplätze
[Musik]
renovieren
ursprünglich glaubten die beiden dass
sie ihr restaurant zwei monate nach
ankunft in den usa eröffnet aber
wegen corona dauerte es nur schon drei
monate bis sie die bewilligungen für den
umbau erhielten dann waren
baumaterialien kaum zu bekommen und
handwerker vielen corona bedingt immer
wieder aus
412 visiert belassen wird sicher ich
glaube an sich haben können wir es ihnen
zeigen
dass sie sich aber so hautnah ich zuvor
gemacht für den drehort im august jede
wieder ja meistens sind zum krieg
so
soll nach einer forderung
ein großer teil ihres ersparten steckten
diesen wenden wegen der verzögerung aber
verlieren sie seit wochen täglich geld
viel geld
[Gelächter]
um mittelfristig das vierjährige
investoren visum zu erhalten
investieren marine und mike viel geld
zu haben zogen jetzt zahle hier
vermutlich aber schon auf
und legen tennis entscheiden sagt
rombach im landtag grundbesitz
musikkorps und
einfach natürlich nur als ganz
ganz immer die
ganze sache
ja dass das visum bekommt und
investieren also augen über dem anteil
kostet es aus
232 tragen können perfekt
ist aber dass wir vermutlich wegen
technischen stand
sehr schön
herzliche menschen erhöht das ist grund
handlich da ändert drum wunsch da ist
eigentlich dafür zu wirklicher hat
amerika in florida
macht mich auch extrem stolz jahr
[Musik]
über nacht ist der schweizer sandro
bauer in frankreich geworden heute merkt
er seine riesige kuhherde zum ersten mal
200 tiere
[Musik]
gilt für alle
gut 6500 liter milch gibt seine holstein
herde täglich patrice modul und eine
melkerin arbeiten mit
sehr effizient ist jedoch dass dort
relativ zügig
trotzdem übersichtlich
was
im schlimmsten fall allein gemalt hat
[Musik]
doch noch wichtiger ist ihm heute das
jungvieh die sieben kälber haben die
erste nacht in frankreich bestens
überstanden
sie haben hunger ein gutes zeichen
[Musik]
wo nicht siehst
während für den vater das neue leben
begonnen hat heißt es für seinen
achtjährigen sohn abschied nehmen
[Musik]
auch die mama ist dabei wenn ihr
jüngster den letzten schultag hat
mir hand für dich noch etwas
ist das ich für den abend großer dank an
alle kinder haben wir 70 mollet und
geschrieben und abstrakter und die hand
noch da drin
und dann hätte er
hatte
es
in hand der duft farb druck gemacht nach
rostow am don massive gamescom dich der
genossen im land aktiv ohne druck
schrieb wieandt das heißt nämlich bis er
hoffe ganz fest dass man
unterscheiden
[Musik]
weil der papa schon weg ist ist ganz gut
da
[Musik]
notartermin in der toskana als
geschäftsführer will philipp heute die
unterschrift unter den kaufvertrag
setzen eine formalie denn der vorvertrag
ist schon lange unterzeichnet seine
maklerin hat aber eine böse überraschung
dass sie die un als versicherer das
landstück sicher keine altlasten im sinn
von
material für grafik macht
jetzt sagt man mir weil ich von meinem
und die dem mann haben wir
wenden das außen ohne bestimmte
unterschrieben und tschüss
heißt ja
ja
dabei bekäme er heute seine schlüssel
fürs gut
[Musik]
im zürcherischen greifen sie arbeitet
die künftige agriturismo besitzerin ifa
noch immer als kindergarten lehrerin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kinder haben evas ganzes leben bestimmt
im beruf und auch privat die 67 jährige
ist mutter von sieben kindern
es ist eva die den größten teil des
geldes für das gut einbringt dafür hat
sie ein haus verkauft die rentnerin ist
froh weiterhin geld verdienen zu können
außerdem verfolgen quark seit gespräch
dauerte schließlich
aber serena und sl und letzten ganz klar
machen ob nicht ein ganzer behörde zeugs
oder honig also träume zur burg
italienischer fan
in der toskana gibt es gute neuigkeiten
der notar hat die forderung des
verkäufers kategorisch abgewiesen die
klausel bleibt
ich muss das sind
die erleichterung ist groß
aber
teile sarkozy zugestimmt
habe
geschäftsführer von agriturismo
mit mit 200
[Musik]
schließlich sagte weil mir die zwei
jahren und über das ganze lachte und ana
maría lópez falsch gemacht
wie immer hast du schon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
florida des sunshine state der südstaat
macht seinem namen alle ehre jeden tag
[Musik]
auch die stimmung der auswanderer ist
prächtig ihr american dream nimmt
nämlich wieder fahrt auf der umbau des
afl shops ist kurz vor der vollendung
zeit die seit langen gekauften und
bezahlten möbel und arbeitsgeräte
endlich auszupacken
doch das ist jetzt wirklich heilig dort
hart stück vor
seiner heimat ein stück also die
tatwaffe ist ein wahrer hergestellten
deutschland ich glaube sie zwei
hersteller
war der umgerüstet das ist dann passt
das funktioniert der stifter also
die warum frage bist du
doch ohne schutz manager zertifikat
keine eröffnung um ein restaurant zu
führen muss man in florida eine prüfung
ablegen themen sind hygiene sicherheit
viren und bakterien im gastgewerbe
ja ich aussehe wer
danach libysche und dem tag machen nach
einem online machen aber darum
dass die bedachte via kamera mit
spiegelt das macht er ja auch als
jungunternehmer müssen die beiden auch
die finanzen im griff haben marina ist
gelernte kauffrau ihr wissen kann sie
nun im eigenen business anwenden noch
aber unterstützt sie buchhalter kennen
architekt controllings
der doppelte buchhaltung meter lang hart
aber ich mache es kann es interessiert
mich was lehrer und
einfach drüber glück etwas
herum wo was wann und wo das mache
holstein ii spare damit nur umsatz
machen
liebe frau muss thomas lammers stoffe
dann
mehr oder weniger bahnhof
[Gelächter]
ist gut dass wir mal das klappt und
zurzeit bereitet gesamt und dann ist es
passiert
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ein neuanfang ohne abschied heute
wandern auch alexandra und john aus die
erwachsenen kinder sascha und journal
bleiben in der schweiz
[Musik]
hey
der ganze stress
stalins
[Musik]
ein tag nach der ankunft in frankreich
ist die übergabe des wohnhauses
[Musik]
[Applaus]
st
der schlager geht's lang
gerade mal zehn monate ist es her dass
sie den hof lee sowie entdeckt hatten im
eiltempo zogen die visa ist die
kaufverhandlungen durch gleichzeitig
verkauften sie ihr heim in oberhof
alexandra sieht das wohnhaus erst zum
zweiten mal
[Musik]
170 quadratmeter hat das haus
so und dann bekommt sogar sein eigenes
badezimmer
[Musik]
ist gar nicht
alles
kaufen
[Musik]
eine riesige garage gehört auch dazu
platz für vier autos die
top profis machen aber
versuchen
[Musik]
die rechnung
es ist sicher um einiges besser wie der
oberhof über no hand wilde müllhalden
über das russische wohnpark sie dass ich
wenigstens bewohnbar ist okay aber da
kam ich ein paar sachen machen vor allem
ich muss immer jeden tab
nein sie ist wirklich gut also nicht
wirklich da einfahren das ist alles
gemacht
[Musik]
vier tage noch und die schweizer feiern
mit monatelanger verspätung das soft
opening eine art generalprobe vor der
richtigen eröffnung
[Musik]
der raum ist wie vorgeschrieben
gestrichen
auch die typischen klinker wände sind
angebracht
[Musik]
als franchise nehmer müssen die beiden
künftigen gastronomen die einrichtungs
vorgaben des hauptgeschäfts einhalten
und monatlich eine gebühr bezahlen
im gegenzug können sie das know how
eines erfolgreichen und erprobten
geschäftsmodells nutzen
doch noch fehlen viele kleine details
also jetzt montiert
sein wann die waffen seien vom nano auf
der rechten seite mädels mittel mit
pflanzen
ja und so gut wie fertig
hoffentlich das um die aber um sie mit
topf genau das ist einfach
vom architekt vor der deutschen
franchise gabmann ist noch nicht diese
stellte netbooks es nahe dass es fertig
ist also vier tage
[Musik]
thomas tore aufmachen im bewusstsein
dass es mir bezirks wie es geht das ist
ein meilenstein
die zürcher haben eine einfache
gesellschaft gegründet eines otto
agricola sämtliche eva ist kapital
geberin philipp administrator der
gesellschaft
bald schon kommen die möbel aus der
schweiz viele davon werden vorerst in
dieser garage eingestellt
[Musik]
nur der kühlschrank hat bereits den
richtigen platz
[Musik]
zweimal habe ich brasilianische ist bei
der bevölkerung
effektive gas abzulassen
maniche der breiteres das ist
[Musik]
auch das nicht
nein nein nein super
ob kennen oder glück nicht passt kann
mit dem bauern von nebenan hat philipp
bereits freundschaft geschlossen
mancher fassade
und der ist völlig unkompliziert
[Applaus]
ja gehts
ja was sagst du es
ist alles
korrekt 92 minuten sind so
philipp und eva hatten sich knapp zwei
jahre gekannt als sie beschlossen sich
auf das abenteuer toskana einzulassen
und eigentlich wäre nun alles auf bestem
wege doch während ihr agriturismo
langsam form annimmt wachsen ifas
zweifel sie stellt ihre beziehung mit
philipp zunehmend in frage
so viel trennt sie zu wenig einziehen
nach langem grübeln der entschluss eva
trennt sich von philipp
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
[Musik]
kommt das erste mal seit der trennung
nach italien rekord mit dem mit dem ding
durch
aus liebe soll freundschaft werden ihr
projekt ziehen sie weiter gemeinsam
entnehmen sie eine bodenprobe des
olivenhaine zahltag in frankreich die
wie saas greifen allein fürs inventar
tief in die tasche
[Musik]
sohn john hat seinen ersten schultag
großeinkauf in tampa morgen ist das soft
opening
[Musik]
es läuft einiges schief
auf und davon mit der mobile
versicherungen und vorsorge